okay i won't ask you how old i will ask
you how old you are okay because you're
young enough that it's probably not
insulting to ask you
so i'm probably only 90 right no why
aren't you 60
why aren't you 60.
[Applause]
why can't you identify as 60 why what
what is the problem with you identifying
as 60.
you're right age is significantly less
important than gender
you can't magically change your gender
the problem with
this entire line of questioning that
she's pursuing here
is that she refuses to define her terms
she and this is the problem with the
entire quote unquote transgender rights
movement what does she mean by sex what
does she mean by gender and this is why
when i say age
right which is a definition we all share
just the way we used to share a
definition of sex
she has no comeback because she
understands you can't arbitrarily
redefine your age but if you're a man
who identifies as a woman
we're all supposed to say oh i guess you
are a woman now